[Music]
hello
listen that's right
we're back we've been gone for a while
but evil does not sleep it stays woke it
stays working hell yeah
right Hassan hell yeah that's right
domestic terrorists
that's true yeah where have we been how
how long has it been since we did our
last show it's just the Classic the
classic uh one episode on one episode
off that's what we've been doing like
divorced parents yeah we just can't it's
a good one we can't uh we can't get like
two weeks in a row together one of these
days it's gonna happen I feel it next
week we're going to do another leftovers
though definitely no we're this it's all
for it's all on from here oh yeah it's
time the last episode was two weeks ago
I guess it's been a little sporadic
we've been in having lots of ends lots
of outs but we're here we're here and uh
that's what matters so Hassan tell me
how have you been
I've been great a birthday recently yes
I am uh unfortunately closer to your age
again well luckily how time works is
that we both move at the same speed yeah
well I don't know I think we'll see what
happens with these aliens and stuff yeah
I mean maybe maybe they got some new
tech
yeah I am 38 by the way
you're not
are you were 42 no you're not no you
want to see my ID 38. I mean it's okay I
believe you doesn't seem that you
believe me I don't really believe you
know because like what does your ID say
about your height you know what I mean
it says 5 11.
okay so then we've already established
that there's lies
you know it's a crime the light of the
federal government and the DMV come get
me [__] I didn't lie to them [__]
they're gonna have to what does it say
about your uh Dome circumference on your
ID well luckily we don't live in a
fascist state that cares about maybe we
should
it doesn't have my Dome circumference
and I'd be like a fascist leader I'm
gonna make everyone put their Dome
circumference no that would be the worst
thing with a rating no no
oh no that would be that'd be my
nightmare [__] F dome right there wow
that's messed up I think uh I will then
move to Korea or Japan we're having like
the appearance of a small head with
broad shoulders is seen as more
attractive what yeah they love
little-headed men it's not it's not that
people have little heads it's more so
that they just love when uh people have
big shoulders and their and their head
looks small in comparison due to that
you ever been to South Korea and see
what the people think about your your
your proportions no but I have talked to
people from South Korea and they love it
they yeah they love the tiny heads yeah
do they like Beetlejuice
ah the movie they're huge David Byrne
fans yeah Beetlejuice is a sex icon
in some little heads I mean yeah you
know haven't you noticed all the all the
BTS guys they look like Beetlejuice take
that back they're all angels all right
I'm going to say that on Jungkook clear
you know we're live right now I know I
know I I'm I'm throwing them up I'm
throwing them up don't worry Jungkook
clear Jason Aldean joking Supremacy
um this is me and you right now Stampy
tears for clear skin we're me and you
leftovers is like the lobby of the
underworld I've never watched this oh
one second oh it's it is actually really
good what what have you ever seen
Beetlejuice is that is it Beetlejuice
yeah what is it like you say Beetlejuice
three times and then he comes to your
house or something it's a it's a zany
crazy dark comedy it's really good I
feel like a lot of this stuff if you
watch with today's eyes for the first
time ever without the Nostalgia Factor
you'd be like ah it's not that great
some that's something to test the time
that one does I think that one does
um so anyway it was your birthday it was
Cam's birthday Dan and Olivia's birthday
all within one week as we've established
previously on this on this broadcast
that July is the best month right okay
come on all right we love July
yeah so um have you seen our musical
debut or our musical duet debuted my
intro yesterday it was beautiful been so
nice yeah I haven't been doing so great
so I I love it yeah I know a lot of
people are saying something oh we that
are quite true doesn't matter if it's
true though
I mean I feel that we could put out an
album
[Music]
I've been relatively critical of uh Ai
and also I've talked about what
advantages it can have
but uh I have been appreciating the AI
Renditions yeah I mean what could what
bad could you say about AI
oh you want me to you're golden me to
talk about Chad gbt I love her at qvt a
little bird and by that I mean foot
soldiers they're coming to my chat told
me that you used why are you guys
snitching on me dude why do you use Chad
gbt like in serious conversations okay
first of all why are you guys snitching
on me second of all Hassan I genuinely
feel that people don't appreciate how
amazing this tool is like really okay
have you ever had a a serious
conversation with jet2p about the Met
Your metaphysical well-being your health
diagnosis is uh your interpersonal
relationships no I'm just kidding I
don't get that defined but but the
problem the problem with igbt like I
mean is content
I've used it a little bit for that
purpose
but the issue is
the AI lies all the time it doesn't
that's a misconception no it it does it
does it does there's no information that
it can pull or if you're asking for it
to say something not true have you ever
seen that happen yourself I have no yeah
yeah I am multiple times no yeah he's a
robot robots can't lie maybe not lie but
it will provide you it gives you
incorrect information extremely
confidently yeah it it gives you what
you want to hear and it doesn't ever
tell you because you're a robot you guys
are a robot oh it's
because of robots I'm just worried
anti-robite I wouldn't use it in debates
is what I mean like I wouldn't use it in
debates because it can give you false
information confidently and Lead You
astray
um
okay yeah I mean listen it can happen
but you can get struck by lightning too
and you still go out no likelihood that
the AI will give you false information
is significantly higher than getting
sure probably I haven't seen the date on
it
[Music]
okay anything else
um I'm just saying always fact check
okay I do I do I do yeah as long as
you're fact checking it then that's good
um I think Bing possibly also will give
you uh their their citations
you could say can you provide citations
and it does and then you can you can
cross check it did you see the the AI
like we used to complete math problems
with relative ease and now like it's
it's not doing it apparently got Dumber
for some reason yeah
for whatever reason from when they
launched it to now has got significantly
worse
and I don't think they know why either I
think we're training it to be stupid
maybe
that has the safeguards to not be racist
though because like you know you
remember the tabot stuff obviously like
Microsoft's first uh interaction with
the AI
yeah it took like 24 hours
I mean dude it's
getting Dumber look at Twitter
I I can't even go on there like
literally it's like I swear to I'm not
exaggerating 50 of my feed is literally
just people trying to uh get a new uh
American Holocaust going
it's it's really that's straight it's
really messed up yeah it's the
confidence of like basement dwelling
Nazis has increased dramatically I
really really don't like that like they
should feel way more insecure about
how shitty their lives are I do think
that people are not going to want to
share that space with them forever and I
I personally have personally
been spending significantly less time on
Twitter have you have you uh I mean I've
already given my social security number
uh my place birth my identification Elon
because I think
I [__] with this Vision you know what I
mean everything app like I think that's
a great idea thanks baby for it's a
great idea uh and I think that Elon is
is gonna be the best at it so here's
where I'm ahead of you this is where I'm
simping even more I'm not giving him
anything I want him to put his chip in
my brain and he can get it himself oh
neuralink yeah oh yeah you can neural
lick me straight into X brother yeah
then you you and Chad gbt could be
besties yeah man right
um actually
um before we get into acts I do want to
talk about that
we talked last time we were here about
Mike pillow's liquidation event
he's selling every goddamn thing in his
office but we had one enterprising young
fupa Trooper who actually cleaned up
rather nicely
my pillow Surplus Industrial Equipment
sale
oh you got a palette of face mask bro
for 10 bucks wait that's
that's pretty good they got they cleaned
up look at this look at all the stuff
they got that's sweet a Pneumatic uh
convertible hand truck with a 800 pound
towing capacity went for 71 dollars I
wonder if you negotiated those prices
down
bro that's wild how cheap this went out
this was a this was a real yard sale
this is Gary vaynerchuk I think is the
one who did this no one is capable of
nobody else I think they're just like
it's gonna cost us more to get rid of
this stuff if you guys don't take it
skill saw 10 portable table a table saw
for 114 dollars damn it it was my
brother's birthday I should have really
I should have spent some time on this
website I could have gotten them so much
more Industrial Equipment 18 door locker
unit 26 dollars six door locker unit why
would that be more you gotta ask
questions about that that was more than
the 18 door well it was a bidding uh
thing maybe there was a little bit of a
bidding war going on you don't you don't
have space for an 18 door locking unit
but you have one for six door so you're
it's understandable but this is really
something I mean we saw those palette of
face masks there's got to be like 10 000
face masks in that thing well at least
and you know no one has ever used those
no like there there is no fear that
anyone could have ever used those face
masks all of it could never survive in
such a god a god-filled uh Place yeah
well congratulations to them
you know
pretty exciting oh one thing real fast
just to mention uh there's a Teddy fresh
restock slash drop this sweater is back
in stock this was a favorite everybody
loves this one
uh the teddy fresh rug all right I need
to I need to get that is back we can cop
one of those I put it next to my husband
rug we'll put it over if you would put
it I'll put it over the husband rug
um I don't know if we have I don't know
what's the deal with those oh we can get
one yeah it's all good if you don't have
it uh oh this is fire yeah this is
Corduroy shirt jacket really nice you
want one yeah done definitely I here's
the thing
I I wear I wear my teddy fresh stuff I'm
wearing it right now I love it bro I uh
I texted Ethan last night I went to see
the Barbie movie
and I realized like in my closet all of
the pink and purple things that I own
because you know you gotta dress for the
theme
uh they're all Teddy Fresh So I was
wearing I was Teddy fresh badass bro I'm
glad you were gonna send him a photo but
I mean in the bathroom I was way too
embarrassed I I just why you didn't you
looked silly you think I don't think I
looked well I mean it's a bit silly like
I don't have The Bravery that Ben
Shapiro hasn't gonna post it I don't
have The Bravery the Ben Shapiro has
where he dressed up exactly like Ken to
go watch the Barbie and Kim movie with a
notepad that's true I'm not as Brave as
he is uh this jacket reversible jacket
is out
oh this is the new one this is when AV
was wearing the other day that everyone
was asking about this is out
This Crew is out
this long t-shirt is out this is back oh
I want that one too you got that Sam
thank you
this is a different color of the
corduroy
whoa that fits wild dude those pants are
that's what's hot right now like massive
Jorts team Stars been ahead of the curve
on that one brother yeah
you know you're gonna you're gonna land
at something fashionable because it's
cyclical right yeah there it is guys uh
Teddy
teddyfresh.com thank you guys so much
all right
um
all right let's talk about the X3
podcast
so we're also rebranding
wait what we're rebranding H is out it's
a cup to letter it's inferior yeah X is
everything so we are known that a X3
podcast in fact we made an announcement
video oh Jesus we're rebranding
everything uh-oh so
and this is kind of inspired by the one
that Elon uh tweeted out retweeted
um maybe I should show that one first
what's this one uh G
yeah check this out this is Twitter's
new uh logo and it's so badass look at
this dude it's X bro
so sick the sound effect
it's so sick
so here's ours inspired by uh
this incredible content
[Music]
oh I get it
let's yeah [__] all right now this is
a big moment the ax finally X3 this
literally this looks like a like a
Silicon Valley bit
I feel like you're about to announce
that you're you're funded by a hedge
fund or something like you got you
raised the 700 million dollars in a
series B throw it up brother X is up we
are X we are the future we are the new
wave of media extremely taking over the
market hell yeah that's right
x marks the spot for excellence
[Music]
yep what was that I'm not sure it
sounded cool though
is that like a hitting a shield I'm
trying to get as close as possible to
the noise that was in the Elon one oh
just like the the impact okay
so uh Elon finally got x.com
congratulations to him x.com now it's
um
redirects to Twitter which is uh
important it didn't every time though
like for the first couple of days it was
having a hard time redirecting because
sometimes it would be like this domain's
owned by GoDaddy like I don't think he
owned it I think he had to buy it yeah
probably paid a fortune for that thing
man he's so God he's such a good
iconic business man yeah he's
Unstoppable he's so smart no he's
Unstoppable force of nature the X style
comp thing really makes sense I mean you
have this established brand with the
bird the name Twitter tweet right is
even part of the Lexicon at this point
it's smart for him to tear that down
after spending 40 billion dollars on it
and just let's start over X yeah I I
really like that you know especially
when like technically Facebook YouTube
Instagram they all have like they all
have likes and comments you know what I
mean like Elon owns for 44 billion
dollars
the naming convention that is so
noticeable and marketable that's been
built for what 20 years now mm-hmm
brilliant that's like you know how
garyvee said this once and it really
resonated with me he goes you know
what's you know what's better than being
born rich
being born poor oh yeah
yeah because I thought you were gonna
say you know because it's better harder
and you know what's better kissing your
dad passionately you know what's better
than being born poor
which you know that's why he's such a
big business guy garyvee was on I think
CNBC different perspective recently and
was already was still glazing up Elon
like that I'm on to be like yeah this is
actually this is brilliant you know he's
just doing a lot for for speech out
there uh he's just doing great he's
doing a great job it's just like how I
just
I think we have a serious problem with
the charlatan economy where uh it's just
like con men propping up oh there's men
propping up other con men they have
class solidarity yeah it's solidarity
yeah I mean it's as quickly my head
quickly gained over 100 million sign up
strong the interest of multiple
companies digital marketing agencies and
advertisers uh businesses that have
stopped advertising on Twitter over
brand safety such a good introduction
with the title The juxtaposition is
perfect it's like Twitter is on fire
they've lost so much market cap and then
Gary comes in and he's like you guys
don't understand this is just like my
father's wine business and it's so sick
I love it Twitter headquarters in San
Francisco is on fire right now they
haven't paid rent in two years they've
fired 90 of their employees and they
have no advertisers Gary tell us why
they're doing great no threads but
reports this morning
now to discuss the state of the digital
ad Market is Gary vaynerchuk a vaynerx
chairman of [__] he's in prison
did you join threads the crypto scams
finally caught up with them no they put
him in prison for kissing his dad yeah
incest is illegal in California I
believe we researched that recently yeah
well thank God he wasn't kissing his dad
in California no no no some states it's
okay to be gay and incest what's your
origin oh gay because you can't have
kids so this if you're gay you can do it
that's I mean that's weird that's like
where's you know where that seems like
liberal propaganda why can the gays have
all the fun you know what I mean right
well it's because they can't have babies
that's the theory that's messed up but
it is it is kind of unfair for sure
he's got some thoughts on that look and
straight people have less rights yeah
this is true
yeah I mean I I cannot have incest like
the gays I watched the Barbie movie last
night men's rights are under attack is
that right yeah did you feel assaulted I
felt so assaulted it was really messed
up I won't get into it because I feel
like we've moved on from it says gone
woke yeah new headline daily wire
um okay go ahead you like it is your
engagement gone down do you do you think
Twitter needs a an alternative a Kinder
gentler alternative
uh I good morning first of all uh I
joined threads I like threads
um I think competition is good uh I
don't I don't know if it's a Kinder
gentler thing I think all of these
places stop off very kind and gentle
when I was on Twitter in 2007 to 2010 it
was the kindest most aspirational joyous
place that was that's so wrong like that
that is just saying that right that is
objectively wrong it was Rejoice bro
less there's always less moderation on
these platforms when they first start
they notoriously let the algo run wild
until people are like hey you have
generated an entire like Army of weird
basement dwelling incel groupers who
just keep talking about how uh Hitler
was awesome actually the new meta the
new wave of like right wing [__] posters
now they've moved Beyond Hitler they now
talk about like the Roman Empire and
talk about how like you know they they
want to just like be gay with their
friends that's similar to Stephen
Crowder mind you
um and and how that was actually you
know that's how things should be like
women shouldn't have rights and men
should [__] each other that's vibes
thank you Twitter for that well if we
know if we don't need women for sex then
what do we need them for
right true if we cut him out of that
they lose all power over breeding I
think that's just like but they're icky
we'll have to do that in the lab yeah
um
he only talks about Twitter being like
gangbusters I think towards the end or
something but he mostly just talks about
how competition is good I don't really
remember exactly where it is but oh do
you guys know where I should watch this
it's pretty long but yeah whatever we
can all right Gary shut up I'm Gary
dumbass nobody cares about Gary I feel
like garyvee fell off dating because
he's free he's a free bird free kisses
dad free to sell you on nfts dude that's
what like okay here's what frustrates me
to no end about the supposed uh
fundamentals backed free market economy
and the stock market in general is that
none of these clowns ever get punished
okay oh no maybe you spoke too soon
who's in jail for kissing his dad though
not for cryptocurrency do we know right
he put him in jail for kissing his dad
which is why okay I'm gonna go free him
he needs to be free okay yeah he doesn't
have any money left because he pumped it
he pumped crypto too hard he actually he
made so much money but he lost it all on
the Apes
wait he did yeah he lost everything on
on board all my Apes gone wait I can't
tell if you're [__] with me or not I
don't know if he ever he knows it's a
scam he wouldn't have spent his money
yeah he he knows this game that's why he
made his own and then he made his own
like was it like a crypto con right yeah
yeah uh at some point garyvee owned
seven uh board Apes so he was pretty all
in on there oh man yeah so elon's been
obsessed with the letter X he uh he was
trying to
um
X originally he wanted to call PayPal
what turned into paypalx.com yeah and I
think I believe that that his um
colleagues thought it was so stupid and
so pointless they ousted him yeah that
was one of the many issues uh with
elon's uh tenure at PayPal where uh I
believe the aspects of coding that he
was involved in as a payment processor
were so awful that uh people could just
like basically break the website and and
move numbers around to their own wallets
originally that was one fundamental flaw
the other one was his insistence on
changing it to x.com which uh many of
the board members thought sounded way
too much like a porn website uh and and
they focus group tested it they tested
it and they were like oh no this looks
like a a porn site we can't do this uh
and then yes Peter Thiel inevitably
ousted him
and took over his role but of course in
under uh capitalist rules if you do have
Capital if you're like in the owner's
status uh you still make hundreds of
millions of dollars when your website
inevitably gets sold which Elon got a
lot of money from PayPal Elon has been
failing up is quite interesting but it
doesn't stop there SpaceX Tesla Model X
he named his son X now he's trying to
make make Twitter x what is going on
with this man the X what's the X
Obsession yeah and the the other
ex-tacion
he named conference rooms in at Twitter
headquarters to like sexy ew and
Exposition I think or something like
it's just very weird well here is his
big global vision for YX why is he
changing the name
this uh brand recognized around the
world to a porn site there's a lot of
great things that are going to come out
um obviously payments down the road
bigger later this year
um and uh
improving the uh direct Master stuff
um obviously enabling full encryption
um
and video and voice calls uh I just
basically solving
like basically we if there's something
you want to do you can do it on the sort
of you know X everything app I want to
kiss my dad how do we make that happen
you'll go to jail don't say yes
okay never mind I don't want to kiss my
dad here's the here's the funny part
about this he's like uh we're gonna do
voice calls video [__] you couldn't
even do like an audio only thing with
Ron DeSantis like last month yeah why
would anybody trust your website
this breaks my heart the current Tesla
Model lines is S 3 X and Y yeah spell
sexy yeah I didn't realize that that's a
shame I'm so glad I don't have any
Teslas anymore that's embarrassing he's
brilliant dude what do you mean sexy so
smart sexy
somewhere else essentially if if Done
Right the
X would be
with certain people's financial needs to
such a degree that over time it would
become I don't know maybe
half of the Global Financial system wow
all right Brady good luck with that one
that sounds great by the way who
wouldn't want one company to own half
the banking Financial system that sounds
so convenient
wow wow Elon is not notorious for like
just straight up you know overshooting
over promising and then not even under
delivering just never delivering uh
that's never happened surely it's not
happening here except the thing is this
is so pathetically Elon because what
he's describing already exists in China
right WeChat already has like
a a similar structure that's what he's
basing it off of right yeah that's what
he's so it's not even a unique or novel
idea and two
meta tried doing this already they
failed to do so in the Western World so
they tried doing it and have
successfully implemented it in certain
countries without infrastructure where
they have a Walled Garden uh internet so
like people that access the internet
know it through accessing Facebook which
you know benefits their numbers greatly
but
uh ultimately
I don't know why Elon thinks that he is
capable of launching this project in
America I don't know why Elon thinks
he's capable of launching this project
at all on Twitter that he is like gutted
entirely
like he can't even manage the the normal
functions of this website that was you
know that had a lot of issues before he
bought it but still was objectively
better you know what I mean I think if
his workers just work a little harder
stay a few hours extra and just show
that they care about their jobs maybe
sleep on the floor a few nights a week
then we can make this we can make this
dream happen
if it fails it's only because if it's
workers we're not yeah they weren't
pulling their weight
here um so this was from a podcast by
this guy zubi oh God I hate this who is
a mega rapper and just like a straight
up like right ring provocateur and they
I guess Elon scouted him
and paid him for this Twitter exclusive
um so this is sponsored by Twitter and
as I was watching this last night
something interesting jumped out to me
here I'll play it right up who wants one
it's not every day you get to talk to a
Visionary like Elon Musk you're lucky to
be able to learn from him on the podcast
and off air when the cameras are off
people feel more comfortable sharing
their personal strategies Millionaires
and billionaires invest in assets to
counter inflation and crazy swings Elon
himself has previously talked about the
little known power of physical assets
real tangible Investments that can hold
their value during a crisis but the real
story a group of everyday investors have
already seen net returns of 10 13 and
even 32 32 they didn't need Millions
because they used Masterworks art
investment platform so it's sponsored by
what seems to me and this is just in my
opinion as a Layman upon these games
it's the weirdest fight they just said
two percent returns listen even Madoff
didn't promise anything I was gonna say
uh this is not Financial advice but like
[__] it it is financial advice anyone
that anyone that tells you that you get
32 returns is stealing money from your
pocket you're oh [__] idiot if you
think that you're gonna make any money
with someone who's like oh yeah you're
gonna get 32 return wait till you hear
their business model check this out so
far Masterworks has sold over 45 million
dollars worth of luxury art handing the
net proceeds right back to investors
luxury art every Master works that looks
luxurious what about art is luxurious
I've never heard I mean all art
technically is a luxury asset you could
say high value R I don't know what's
luxurious I mean they're they're just
like they they it's a it's a scheme for
wealthy people to like uh hide their
sure yeah their assets which is why this
makesable even less sense or has
delivered a return look at this guy dude
that guy's living [__] with
Masterwork brother if you ever see this
b-roll you're being
yeah
straight up
dude I I just already invested over bro
you're being scammed right now the more
the more desperate people become the
more circumstances worsen under
capitalism the more I feel like people
are getting dumber and dumber because
they're like I just want to believe like
[__] you that that's the attitude that a
lot of people have but it's like but
you're getting scammed
half a billion dollars with them
offerings can sell out in minutes but
zoobie listeners can skip the wait list
by going to masterworks.com and entering
the promo code zubi z-u-b-y in the how
did you hear about us box that's
masterworks.com and use the promo code
so so you give them your money and what
they say they do with it is that they
buy
Picasso's valuable art and then they
they're willing and dealing picassos
and then the profit is being returned to
you the investor that is the craziest
[__] thing
at least they moved on from nfts to like
back to real physical products that's
true that they're still uh running
schemes on love that so there it is guys
get hold over Masterworks you can own a
piece of a of a Picasso here's the thing
I will never understand
this guy has led you astray probably a
million times over why do you still
believe him like his his one goal is to
make you money he's taken money from you
how the [__] do you ever trust him after
that like fool me once you know shame on
you fool me twice shame on me right
what's happening why are you guys
getting fooled like 10 times when has he
stole their money any other if you look
through his profile I'm sure he's done
more uh you know crypto [__] do you
think about the mega rapper or either
the Maga rapper Elon Musk every single
one of these people uh including all the
blue check mark weirdos that are at the
top of every single reply now they all
are peddling some kind of pump and dump
scheme to other people in their in their
immediate vicinity everyone's become
like a life insurance Peddler and it's
it's so frustrating but it doesn't make
sense like how would how is this economy
still alive it's I guess that it's like
they say there's a there's a sucker born
every minute I mean I don't know what to
say some people are just marks yeah you
know
I I just I I will never understand it I
don't know why uh the people are
they they're so ride or die for these
kinds of schemes I guess it's just like
they're selling them a dream a financial
success so I guess that's why it's so
successful I just I do feel like it's
getting worse and worse though
um
I'm sorry what I'm just kidding
um let's see so there it is good luck
too
ax of course there's going to be some
speed bumps one uh unfortunately being
that meta owns the trademark Forex and
unfortunately it owns the trademark for
X in online social network services
online social network Services namely
facilitating social introductions or
interactions among individuals uh social
networking service in the field of
entertainment gaming application
development providing information about
social networks that involve online
gaming online video games online video
game applications providing an internet
website protocol for engaging in social
networks providing information news
commentary in the field of social
networking so hopefully you can find
some space in that to carve out for
himself because I'm sure that Meadow
won't mind there's so many other funny
issues that has arise from this like
Japan loves Twitter they use it a lot oh
they're they're way more active on
Twitter yeah it's very popular it's a
weird it's kind of like completely
insulated from America American Twitter
but
um a much larger percentage of Japanese
users use Twitter like online than
Americans
and uh X Japan is a J-Rock group so they
can't even they can't own that one like
they just can't brand it as like Twitter
X Japan
it's really well thought out it's a
really well conceived the idea yeah uh
Microsoft has owned this x trademark
since 2003.
so the way I see it is
um so Elon Musk
wanted to take down the the Twitter logo
on the side of the headquarters in San
Francisco
and of course he fired everybody so
there was no one to be like hey we need
to get a permit for this right right and
the cops came and they stopped them and
then they were forced to continue
because there's exposed wiring at this
point right so it's an even bigger
Danger
and to me that is exactly how Elon
operates he's a micromanager he's Petty
he oftentimes makes decisions like on
the Fly and because he's so profoundly
wealthy in a system that just rewards
incompetent con men uh that uh for one
reason or another have been able to
accumulate wealth
that
he feels like he could just always get
away with it he can always fail upwards
and that's how I feel about this
decision this massive decision that by
every metric is idiotic to just change
the name of Twitter to X it feels so on
the spot it feels so stupid it goes
against all of the business principles
right and yet he's like well who's gonna
tell me no I'm the richest guy on the
planet
well not anymore I think Bernard Arno is
the original not even uh Gates passed
him again I saw idiot right there what a
[__] beta but um it's hard for me to
decide is this just like him
insisting on getting his way or is he
trying to intentionally bankrupt the
company
I don't know why but that seems to be
what he's doing
what I have realized and what I was
wrong on what I what I was right on was
I knew that this was going to be an
objective failure because Elon Musk an
idiot but what I was wrong on is that I
thought maybe more people would have
noticed that Elon Musk is a [__]
idiot and then that given his key man a
situation at Tesla being such a
profoundly important uh person like a
singular Force for Tesla stock would
have translated to his uh would have
translated to Tesla stock also going
down I was wrong about that uh I'm
willing to admit that no matter how much
Elon Musk fails it seems like Tesla
stock still is uh going to
uh have a mind of its own basically yeah
I mean it's going to come down I think
as competition goes up it's going to
come down oh yeah with other EVS
entering the market for sure but um
moving on actually he is the richest guy
in the world still as of July 26th yep
he's number one baby
239 Billy let's [__] get it
um
let's talk about [__] Mick I can't say
the what I really want to say [__] mix
c word
oh yeah you'll get you'll get yellowed
for that so Mitch McConnell who is a
demon in a human skin
actually died on television last night
which is awesome
is it okay to say that I'm if he died
I'd be happy I mean I don't know [__]
I've said it I've said way worse [__]
yeah I wouldn't like I didn't know it's
taboo to not like be like oh I'd be
happy if he died I would be though like
I don't know him he's not my grandpa I'd
just be like dope that's one less
problem yeah
I mean I watched a video from
Peter's Antonello I think his name is
a relatively big travel YouTuber who
went to the Appalachian area
and he went to West Virginia he went to
Virginia and he went to Kentucky to talk
to a bunch of coal miners that were left
behind
and when you see the situation in
Kentucky overall
it's very difficult not to have so much
disdain and so much anger and so much
hatred for its Representatives that very
actively work against the interest of
its citizens
um Mitch McConnell being uh one of the
leading causes of all the problems that
the people's uh people experience in
places that are forgotten like that so I
mean I've always had a tremendous amount
of animosity towards him I think he is a
horrifying demon but uh there is no
karmic Justice in this world
and Mitch McConnell just like all these
other [__] uh lizard demons like
Henry Kissinger like Dick Cheney never
actually they look so unhealthy and yet
they live so long and they accuse they
accusing other people of drinking baby
blood to live long yeah how do you think
these [__] guys who look like they've
been on death's doorstep for 20 years
Keep On this man's been in Congress he's
been dead for 20 years
look at this here here's Mitch McConnell
uh giving a press conference and how far
into his term is he how many how many
years left does he have he's got he's
running for re-election too I'm sure I
don't think he is uh but he just
recently won re-election yeah so he's
got a good four seasons he ripped uh Amy
McGrath Amy McGrath that's right hey
shredders yeah did you guys say hi to
Kaya
oh
hi puppies hello welcome
hi
did they say hi
they're playing the doggies are saying
hi
I'm just listening to see if they're
if everybody's here they're happy
they're they're I don't see any I didn't
hear any barking yet yeah yeah that's
pretty good it's progress
um
anyway let's just watch the damn thing
so here he is
well good afternoon everyone
yes uh we're on a path to finishing the
NDA also it's definitely Confederate tie
this week that tie is giving Confederate
flag operation
his lips are blue this man is not
getting oxygen seen a photo of his hands
from like 2020. you remember that yeah
oh yeah it looked like he was decaying
yeah actively
dude this man's lips are blue he needs
life support
I don't think it's normal for your lips
to be blue you're jealousy so hot his
corpse is cold that's what it is his
body's old
he's sexy and he knows it well yeah I
like I I've I've pointed out a few of
these guys uh Trump included have such a
[__] tight little nussy oh my [__]
oh yeah
that neck [__] goes crazy
[Music]
oh let me go back so you guys
what's happening
okay
anyway Mitch McConnell huh
yeah I mean Mitch McConnell what's his
legacy he's just like a pure
obstructionist
uh dirty
[__]
yeah so Mitch McConnell is
um
a a horrifying demon who basically
uh he he took the idea that if you run
an obstructionist uh if you run an
obstructionist Senate
uh you will not get punished
by the Republican party and he tested it
out any any realized that that was the
case yeah like before Mitch McConnell
he's not singularly individual
responsible for this obviously the
structures at hand are are what has
borne of what has created as a result
but he was the first who said I am going
to make sure that Obama
is a one-term president he uh he he
hampered uh economic relief uh efforts
which of course uh were
like they were fairly significant and
caused by uh the the Republican party's
failures leading up to this moment
um he he did everything he could to
obstruct uh the the uh Democratic
policies under Obama when they had a
super majority in the Senate I will
never forgive the Democrats for allowing
that to happen either but basically
since
in The post-mitch McConnell era
Republicans always run uh the the
obstructionist policies where they just
their goal isn't necessarily to
legislate
their goal is to just stop any
legislation from happening to get any
leverage they can yeah and it's quite
sad and pathetic and it's and it's it's
something that has uh never really
punished them that well the influence on
like people think that Congress is
useless and I mean his influence alone
has basically ensured the uselessness of
Congress for like decades to come anyway
Harry is dying on live TV
which makes me happy
and I'm not wishing for it I don't I
don't wish for it but now that it's
happened I can say that it makes me
happy yeah I just don't think it will
happen because these [__] never
die well he's out he's got an iv a baby
blood right in Marina evil Never Dies
unfortunately he's literally munching on
you know he did he this man eats dried
babies like [__] prunes he is an
adrenal Chrome recipient they dry they
put babies out and dry them out in the
sun for a month and they come out like
prunes and Mitch McConnell eats them
like Tic Tacs oh 100 people good
afternoon everyone he came back after
this oh well yeah I've got I've got them
both we're on a path to finishing the
NDA uh
this week it's been good about ours in
cooperation
and a string of uh uh
go on
so
so this is one of the most powerful
people in government
bro you know what happened here
there's a piece of the death note on
there he touched it on accident he
started seeing the Shinigami in the
crowd that's what's going on and the
Shinigami was like
I'm here for you [__] can I ask you a
question and what profession would
something like this not result in their
immediate retiring
this this is the only one the most
important one well I guess like CEOs or
like Founders CEO oh founder okay you're
an owner of a company they can get away
with a lot like yeah because they own it
nobody can tell them especially if it's
like a private company yeah like family
owned
anyway
um this is the geriat geratocracy that
we live in they're all old as [__] he's
old Feinstein got wheeled in there
Nancy Pelosi's old as hell even though
Joe Biden even though
[Music]
even though Nancy's titties are supple
oh God she you're not wrong she herself
is yes yes her I was wondering if that
was uh appropriate or not carbon dating
uh successful carbon dating uh measures
of take have been taken on her boobs
they're they have the age of like 35 I
think it's pretty interesting yeah but
anyway
um everybody's too oiled they will not
step aside young people it's our time to
do [__] okay go [__] die quickly
and quiet please because I didn't want
to see you anymore and let's move on all
of you there's plenty of demons that are
young too that are willing to do this
exact same job uh this to me fine fine
let them there's so many I don't want to
see old people anymore demons yeah let's
get fresh demons out here like there's
so many things are frustrating me about
this because it's like one it shows that
this is on autopilot you know what I
mean you're just like you put a monkey
in that suit and we already know that
they don't write the legislation they
don't read the legislation lobbyists do
that for them and they're just there to
basically push for it they're there
inside trade yeah uh do a little bit of
inside trading uh you know offer
favorable contracts to or favorable
positions in government to their wives
uh or you know their their next of kin
whatever
that's their job is to just milk the
American taxpayer dry as they uh keep
everybody busy focusing on really
idiotic dumb culture War uh ideas and
battles it is deeply frustrating to me
to see a person benefit from Platinum
Healthcare
like the best health care on the planet
do you know how much the government's
spending just to keep that man alive
exactly it's it's very very frustrating
to see that especially when one of his
jobs is to basically stop that from
stop that uh that Health Care from ever
uh being achieved for the average
constituent that he has in a place like
Kentucky in the Appalachian region in
general conditions are worse than a
third world country a developing Nation
um 100 like the the outcomes like Health
Care outcomes in places like Kentucky in
places like West Virginia are worse than
uh places like Bangladesh which is
insane this is the richest country on
the planet what good is all of this uh
endless imperialism if the Imperial
Corps is not even reaping some of the
marginal rewards of it and Mitch
McConnell is one of the people that is
responsible for not letting you have any
of that
so
uh yeah no I I do uh celebrate it I do
get excited at the prospect of him uh
having a a horrifying uh you know
painful existence where he's just
basically trapped in his own mind he's
like fully aware of what's going on but
he's in a comatose-like structure I'm
not going that far I'm not hey YouTube
I'm not saying that I'm
he's just an awful demon dude I mean and
many of these Democrats are in in a
similar uh playing field as well make no
mistake a lot of these guys are [__]
you over actively they are causing so
Much Death destruction harm and they're
making a tidy profit off of it and it's
very frustrating to see them get away
with it year over year over year as
people feel less and less power more and
more powerless uh in the face of these
unjustifiable structures this is did you
show this image yeah I think you might
be right
although the the theory that he saw the
Grim Reaper or something is pretty
interesting like let if you watch this
back Lucifer do you have a crowd do you
have like a death bell uh like Zach no
like actually like like an actual Death
Note yeah yeah because what I'm thinking
of doing is
here we have an alternative angle I
think he's stroked out by the way
straight up but he came back how could
he have a stroke and then come back I
mean I don't know they probably hit him
with some crazy
liquid cocaine in the bag or something I
don't I my first guess would be a stroke
but the fact that he came back makes me
think I mean his half of his face was
like Sloopy I can't see uh I need
somebody to move the
Hassan's TV a little over because I
can't see the bottom right
so what I want to do is kind of just
thank you role play a little bit here
now just the gong please
so I'm going to start with the audio
okay
here it is
[Music]
here's the Bell
he knows who it tolls for he sees the
face of his father in the crowd but his
father has a dark Hood over his face and
a giant sickle in his hand he says Mitch
it's time your time has come you're past
your time Mitch
let go you're on one HB Midge there he
goes you're hanging up by a thread and
and he feels the lick of the flame below
him as hell calls for him your soul is
mine
we made a deal Mitch
his breath the brand on in the back of
his neck starts bleeding his soul has
been claimed by the underworld have you
seen pull up the photo of his hands this
is from two years three years ago at
this point those are pretty great Mitch
I don't know how he didn't die
yet
well I do know how he didn't die because
hey guess what if you live in Kentucky
yeah
what the [__] if you live in in the
state of Kentucky if you live in uh in
really any Red State any rural area as a
matter of fact there's not a [__]
Hospital in like a 200 300 mile radius
for you okay go to your hands look black
like that yeah what I don't know
reanimation dark magic he is what yeah
he was on ironically he was he was I
mean he's decaying in front of our eyes
genuinely does anybody know what medical
condition makes your hand turn black I
think that's when you try to destroy
horcrux maybe but I know but we're
joking about dark magic but what
glitched him I think he's actually just
a lich he's a lit it's when you shake
your hands with the Devil right right
right right oh wait like burned it yeah
yeah so I don't I don't think we have
any real return on that investment is
like what 10 more years Mr devil man I
really want to make sure that everybody
dies okay this is interesting this is
what Dumbledore's hand looked like after
he destroyed the horcrux yeah oh wow so
that is actually an interesting Theory
do you think he's a good guy well whose
four quick did he destroy that is the
question interesting maybe he is I
forgot what it's a Harry Potter thing I
I put his soul into little things yeah
yeah because he was in Immortal and then
for those of you who don't remember
Mitch McConnell also fell uh and that
was big news uh he fell and he was away
from uh cameras for a while
for six weeks he was out that was Travis
Scott falling off stage oh
what did you say I feel like it might be
bruising are you making fun of my son
and I misspelled Bruce
Bruce I ain't never seen bruising that
looked like decaying flesh
but I don't know no it's these guys all
have like a lot of blood circulation
problems at that age probably due to the
medicine that they're taking due to
other medical conditions like Health
Care problems there was a vox.com
article from 2017.
uh which is always good to resurface
where some some pharmacist and on the
hill straight up was like I write
dementia medication for congresspersons
in 2017 right you know what I mean like
I write dementia medication for not one
multiple people in Congress
pharmacist says he's filled Alzheimer's
prescription medicines for members of
Congress awesome
they're like no I don't have it I'm just
preparing This falls into a unique
territory where on the one hand it's
obviously a direct hip violation to to
reveal medical records but also it's
tell us certainly in the public uh
interest to know who the [__] is like
tell us who they are yeah we don't have
to tell us I know it is it's Dianne
Feinstein it could be no honestly it's a
Target Rich environment it could be many
it could be a lot of Congress persons
think about it
I think the only way to act is just get
rid of all of them not to kill them to
fire them yeah that's I just wanted to
make that very clear
because right was that clear yes
okay yes they should be no longer
elected they should not be eligible no
yeah you know lots of you know anyway
here he comes back
uh so this is why I think he didn't have
a stroke and he probably just destroyed
a horcrux
could you address what happened here
like what the [__] just happened press
conference and it was related to your
injury from earlier this year where you
suffered a concussion is that suck
you find you're fully able to do your
job you know he's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh sir what just happened are you
able to do your job uh yeah I'm fine
next question
it's one of those things where it's like
are you that old or did you just have a
stroke and that's why half of your face
is like droopy
you know what I mean
why can't we have anything good
is it
you okay okay
they just just wheeled them out
we 100 are not getting leftovers two
weeks in a row God damn it
it's just you can't we can't do it it's
the curse I think I think everything's
gonna be okay
um just um just one moment just hang
tight
nothing out of the ordinary going on
it's all good people it's all good
is
anyway
um
it's gonna be uh it's a year since the
IRA passed and
uh we got a lot of good uh legislation
coming up on the docket
uh yeah nothing to see here folks
Ethan did not die
yeah no he's uh he's definitely alive
yeah and um he's definitely a person
who's all all four chambers of his heart
is they're working they're functioning
they're pumping blood as as any person's
heart would do I told him not to eat
that frozen pizza and he didn't listen
to me
but of course he's fine he's fine folks
he's fine
oh here he comes now
what happened buddy you good yeah yeah
okay
all right
sure
yeah okay
no questions please
hi everyone all right get out of here
come on George
so there he is we love him we love our
uh
our government officials don't we folks
there's nothing certainly there's
there's nothing wrong with having like
800 year old vampires around the country
I mean it's not them then who hanging
out
puppies it's 800 years of wisdom
I feel like she's so big she's so big
she's about to show up on camera like
next week when she's almost done near
you oh you got a shot good Shredder is
getting along really well with her today
oh
[Music]
ready
he just wants to say hi
she sometimes does have a tendency to be
a little Annoying for the record
especially with like smaller dogs she
doesn't really know how big she is so
she'll like try to play
and frustrate the older dog could she
know she's a different size every week a
[__] dog just last week she was
Shredder's size yeah yeah
he's so sweet
I'm a cool dad now you jerk her off yet
absolutely not
even though it's like
um I've never I've never had a female
dog and um I think she's probably gonna
have to go through her first or maybe
even second heat cycle and when that
happens I have to put a diaper on her
really yeah because I I haven't spayed
her yet
I will are you waiting to us for a
certain I am waiting uh for at least
like a year and a half maybe two years
that's what they told us about Shredder
to wait till he was two wait really it's
usually they usually like vets it
differs but
um the Vets I've spoken to and the
professionals I've spoken to
firmly believe that for larger dog
breeds especially in order to avoid hip
dysplasia later later on Vibes like they
need to fully develop uh their bodies
before they get spayed or neutered I
guess it's a it's a debated topic and
veterinarian science but uh I'll tell
you those two years leading up Shredder
was a menace oh really he was humping
every goddamn thing that moved man yeah
you'd have a teddy bear that he [__]
the [__] up dude that thing was like
paper mache I I got uh I I got fish
neutered at like a year and a half and
he never actually humped anything which
was great oh yeah I I do I do worry
though because uh apparently when
they're in heat their attitude changes
uh so I'm a little worried about that I
can say though for sure I was I was
really worried about
Shredder personality changing once we
neutered him but
he was the same great dog just like way
better way better
you know it was really good for him yeah
oh it's ready what they just want to say
hi
oh
she's just standing there
she's just standing there Shredder
trying to go under my leg
you're trying to go under my leg
I am a puppy Shredder
you're just a puppy
look how big she is
hello
we're ready you're like an old man dog
now
what are you looking at it's a baby
Scooby Dooby Doo so what we have left uh
we have Trump gets indicted he did every
I did everything right and they indicted
me for a third time I did everything
right and they indicted me yeah he's
about to get arrested again
uh relating to the fake
electors
which is fantastic we love that three
indictments
um
that was a perfect phone call Ethan I
heard it it was perfectly [__]
incriminating
his team had to his team tried to
actively I mean they tried to take it
all the way to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court was like no this is a
valid case even his crooked ass Goofy
absurd
you know Supreme Court here here's what
he had to say about his coming third
indictment disgusting I would tell Putin
got a set oh no sorry sorry I'm getting
ahead of myself this is uh when he's
elected this is what he's going to do in
the Ukraine and Ukraine to resolve the
dispute I would tell Putin got to settle
tell zelinski you gotta settle I would
tell one you're gonna load up with money
I tell the other you're not gonna get
any money I would get a settlement in 24
hours part of the deal baby it never
happened you have thousands
simple right now hundreds of thousands
who have cities that are obliterated I
don't know if you've ever seen the
cities after they finish with the
Rockets you have cities with no building
standing it looks like just a demolition
Zone
I would tell you might say it looks like
a war zone yeah but he's I mean it
sounds pretty sound yeah
he's like yeah
he could stop he'd stop it I don't even
think that I don't think you could
probably resolve any issue
between two people and the entire world
by doing that me the like you could go
to playground Elementary playground
listen Bobby you got a center
he he's the boss baby he's like a big
version of that that movie The Boss baby
think boss baby's more confident
frankly
boss baby has he has plans yeah
uh here he is he's talking about how he
loves president XI of China he's a
bigger G simp than I am it's wild kind
of crazy just repeatedly say stuff like
that and how do Republicans like they're
constantly talking about how bad China
China's the Boogie comes on and also
they made covid apparently that's their
narrative right which I don't believe
right just to be clear that's not true
as far as I can tell as far as I know
but they think they say China made kovid
to uh
don't ask RFK what he thinks
RFK thinks the Jews made covet to kill
bite and black people you could not have
found it like a funnier group to to
claim never get sick then Ashkenazi
juice
like yeah I'm literally in the exactly
do you not know a single Ashkenazi
Jewish person in your life or in your
immediate vicinity
right through hell we're sickly people
it's just like you know like lactose
Zach are you sickly you're full
Ashkenazi
um am I sickly yeah what's your problem
for your medical issues uh more mental
Than Physical but uh okay well you're
still young those are coming yeah how
old are you you're I'm gonna be 26 next
month okay yeah you're you're gonna get
some [__] up disease I'm sure I can't
wait dude oh I'm kidding nah because
it's you're it's right it's true it's
just life it's it's like a it is a it's
a meme like uh hold on do you either
your parents have
one time do you know where your parents
were around the time of 2019 to 2001 uh
on the weekends because wait 2019 to
2001 yes because that's when these
meetings were happening between the
Chinese and the Jews oh right also um
wait that it's just like such an insane
conspiracy that I love thinking about it
and like trying to unpack it where it's
like
why are the Chinese only doing a carve
out
for Jewish people but not all Jewish
people just Ashkenazi Jews yeah no we
don't want the Sephardic ones they can
perish with the rest of them yeah it's
like a very strange it's such a very
strange not very well thought out we're
talking about RFK Jr who is like just
when I saw that I was like oh [__] new
anti-Semitism just dropped yeah which is
but it but it's also strange because
then it's like well first of all
literally look at like originally when
Kobe was happening they always said like
well everyone in Israel got vaccinated
and they're still dying so like what
happened you just like reverse the
narrative now it's like just kidding
everyone in Israel got vaccinated and no
one died also it doesn't it doesn't make
sense like so so like it's it is a bio
weapon
but like you also shouldn't get
vaccinated you shouldn't protect
yourself against it you shouldn't mask
like it's all part of the same plan why
don't you understand Hassan it's just
that we I created the virus
so that people would get vaccinated and
that's how I control them bro don't you
get it the virus isn't isn't the end I'm
coming up big time from this covet yeah
let me tell you step step two profit
question mark what's the how does that
work I can't explain step two yeah
you're not you're not ready for that
access level uh here's Trump talking
about President XI who is a humanitarian
God
and here he is
I think if president XI Central Casting
brilliant guy you know when I say what
does he mean Central County that means
like he's handsome like that like a
Hollywood guy yeah you know that's just
one of his favorite companies yeah
casting one that's a high that's one of
the highest honors you can get from
Trump to be fair to be fair uh I think
this is an interesting strategy because
I can't imagine that President XI has
been called handsome by many other world
leaders oh excuse me no I just it's an
unusual it's very handsome even if he is
the most beautiful man in the world it's
just not a compliment you usually get
paid by world leaders he's a handsome
devil that cheap beautiful hairline
those are beautiful hairline yeah really
nice hairline yeah
[__] man nice color
yeah a nice like a little bit of that
gray for yeah and you know a touch of uh
he's raised up dude yeah yeah honey the
poo ass looking [__]
you get put to death by honey
Winnie the Pooh yeah no I don't think
they killed it bro they throw you to
underground some
I saw that on Reddit yeah yeah I'm sure
that's true I get all my information on
China uh from Reddit yeah
everyone says oh that's terrible
it runs 1.4 billion people get an iron
fist smart Bridge perfect there's nobody
in Hollywood like this guy
what do you mean in a hall yeah there's
nobody in Hollywood who's running one up
who's uh like communist dictator
practically I don't know you're right
yeah well I mean
I don't I don't know how he can get away
with saying any of this to be honest
like I I do really I am really shocked
by this because I feel like when I say
things like this unironically people get
very mad at me like even liberals get
very mad at me yeah
um you know if Joe body could you
imagine Joe Biden like even
subtly saying like uh she's actually a
good guy Jack or something like that
like he's handsome like they would
literally eviscerate here's why I think
they let it go it's because Trump isn't
confident he doesn't do anything right
they're used to they have to infer they
have to create their own lore around
everything they does they're probably
like this is 5D chess he's just
buttering him up for this big plan he's
got to dominate China but he's done this
so many times like he did it with
duterte he he did it with Kim Jong-un
like he is he is definitely fond of uh
authoritarian uh leadership for sure
there's nobody in Hollywood like him
which I find very strange I mean do I
think this will yield uh positive
results in a in a potential multi-polar
World absolutely not I don't think that
I mean I think he's going to continue
being as gung-ho and anti-china as
possible which is
which is why you know I I just I don't
really get how he can get away with
saying stuff like this but I guess
because they own patriotism they can say
whatever the [__] they want and not
really get dinged by the American
population one more time here I'm gonna
run it back brilliant guy you know when
I say it's brilliant everybody says oh
that's terrible you call it well he runs
1.4 billion people with an iron fist
Iron Fist is not I don't think that's
necessarily a compliment yeah I don't
know he thinks it is though that's not
what we said about like Stalin
he loves that though like that's so this
is one thing that uh he openly has said
is cool which is uh like more
authoritarian measures of governance
he likes it 100 and Iron Fist
not even saying that like uh G is as uh
as despotic uh of a dictator as the way
uh American Media is presenting him but
I mean I knew you would be a China simp
oh I mean I'm I'm openly a China simp I
think that the saddest part about it is
that we never get like any of the good
stuff that China's doing and only look
at the bad stuff that they're doing and
then Implement those things like
like America already has a surveillance
State uh similar to the Chinese
surveillance day we already have the
credit score uh and then on top of that
like we get none of the high speed rail
we get none of the even uh uh
development housing we get none of the
uh Chinese Prosperity massive middle
class no no billionaires are punished
ever right no no government officials
that are engaged in corruption are
punished ever alongside the billionaires
it's true you're I think it's true it is
pretty incredible what China's done yeah
the past 50 years it's almost like
miraculous what's happened there yeah I
saw a Chinese guy saying like people
don't talk about like the fact that like
six or I don't know what's the number
but like 60 of Chinese peasants in the
last 50 years were pulled out into
middle class everybody's life has vastly
improved they do talk about it they just
hide it they always P like the world
economic Forum or the World Bank will
come out with a report they'll be like
capitalism is the greatest system of all
time look at the billions of people that
have been lifted out of poverty China's
not exactly not capitalism no no uh they
of course they they are uh complete
state-run they have a unique uh well in
their words the transitional social
estate that much I don't know how true
that is right but
um having said that the reason for their
the reason for their prosperity is
directly a consequence of what they did
with the influx of foreign Capital right
because plenty of Nations get foreign
capital and don't engage in even
development urbanization increasing
literacy focusing on education programs
and China still has plenty of issues
especially in the health care sector
they have a lot of problems and
obviously uh civil liberties uh that's a
that's a big point of contention as well
um but overall the reason why they've
been able to do this is because they
have implemented plenty of measures that
you absolutely could even by European
standards consider Social Democratic
principles it's pretty incredible
honestly yeah and he goes of course the
people of China like Chi like he's
improved everybody's life there
dramatically I was like okay fair enough
you know what I mean Chinese people I
talk to well once they're done being
shocked that I'm not actually being
sarcastic whenever I talk about China
will often say that it's well
established everybody understands that
there are certain things you can't say
in even private settings and as long as
you keep your head down there is a
cultural understanding that
um the government is taking care of you
and uh and that like the wonderful
prosperous the wonderful Prosperity that
you have experienced that your
grandparents and your parents have
experienced is very real very noticeable
and you have this mentality where like
as long as you don't rock the boat as
long as you don't say the Winnie the
Pooh if that's like a sillier version of
that but like as long as you're not
openly and heavily critical uh in ways
uh of like the the local governance or
uh the CCP or Gigi ping then you know
you have this shared understanding that
is
I mean we I don't think we should
downplay the
absolute uh lack of free free speech
there oh no I I'm not downplaying that
at all but but there's a reason why I
don't live in China and I live in
America you know what I mean
what do you have a choice
I would live in China 100 I I want to
know that can people move to China
Americans
um it's entirely dependent on I guess
your relationship with businesses there
yeah there's plenty of people that go
and live there over extended periods of
time they work there go to China you
I do want to go my fear is uh you know I
may not have said some things about
xinjiang back in the day that uh are not
you think they're waiting for you no but
like I just from what I understand I
would just like have my Visa denied
probably before I ever stepped foot and
I gotta say it that's impressive
bureaucracy if they can be like this guy
talk [__] 20 years ago Visa denied
that's not even 20 years ago though I'm
just saying you got to give it up to the
boy yeah uh you know I am I am critical
of certain aspects of China which you
can't really don't they have uyghur
death camps is that it's not a death
camp it's it's uh they were they were
re-education camps uh and they are no
longer in operation is that recorded the
Associated Press
okay I saw this laser documentary and I
don't know I I I don't know
the I don't know the surrounding uh
narrative or anything about it but it
was about
um
they were there was doctors in the area
they would be able to procure organs no
that's not no I'm telling you they were
they were in China that okay that one is
like shenyon
you in Oregon
um from a leaguer
but why is that is that really that
crazy no there is no no you're not wrong
there's actually a black market for uh
organs or was a black market for organs
100 uh it's not exclusive to uh uyvers
and uh it's it's uh propagandized
heavily it's obviously [__] up but it
was propagandized heavily by uh falun
gong which is a psychotic reactionary
insane cult the the ones that operate
the shenyon
you know what I'm talking about you know
about shenyon you know what shenyon is
like is that five thousand dollars hold
on that was the show on uh Netflix where
he
no I don't know what you're going for
here but nope you know you ever see
these Billboards all around La it's like
Glendale oh that's a Vibe China before
communism yeah they're they're crazy
like the cult that uh puts this show on
is like pretty wild what's wrong with
China before communism
um well they are the the guys that make
it and the guys that uh you know
they the the guys that like bake
propaganda into Shen Yun are pretty
insane like they they think that uh
nuclear reactors were actually found in
China before communism that
miscegenation should be illegal no race
mixing uh they're not too fond of gay
people they're they're pretty crazy guys
of course yeah they're and of course
they get funding and and at least like
they're saying the whole uighur thing is
propaganda or mostly propaganda no no no
no no I don't I'm not saying that I do
think that they engaged so
uh it's a It's Tricky territory to to
get into because every state does awful
things in China the Chinese State
certainly has
um the the mass surveillance date in
xinjiang uh the ugar Muslims in the in
the constant surveillance they were
placed under and uh that that is still
ongoing for the record
and uh the re-education camps were
completely [__] up but as far as I
understand their goal in like wiping out
any kind of separationist attitude
uh has been successful in that now
xinjiang is not necessarily honified but
at least like their cultural components
are considered something that you can
observe as like a tourist destination
rather than
um a legitimate stake in in autonomy or
or any kind of like separation from the
Chinese State here's Hassan uh trying to
get his Visa
I would never do that looks dicey out
there I would never do that make the
rich pay
you would wear that in China
anyway
uh shout out uyghurs I guess
[Music]
yeah for I do think that they absolutely
have uh an operated re-education camps
which is you know not great that's
really [__] up
um
the the common like the
but it says if it's everything that uh
China or any other foreign adversary of
the United States does that is like
greatly emphasized and and Hyper focused
on as though it's like unique to the
country itself like for example prisons
in uh prisons in our foreign adversary
nations are called labor camps even
though America
objectively has more prisoners per
capita than every single one of these
countries including China or has a way
more Draconian prison system where
there's slavery inside of our prison
system that's constitutionally allowed
um they they'll open up museums and the
New York Times will write an article
about how like their museums are
engaging in uh you know whitewashing
their atrocious crimes throughout
history and it's like well that's
precisely what our Museum can I ask you
something it seems amongst socialists
like yourself there's like an over
I feel like you all are overly generous
to China
some people are I don't think I am I I I
look at the bad and I look at the good
like I'm sure that they are deaf I mean
they're definitely
uh
uh over uh I don't think it's
appropriate to put uh uh [__] I can't
think like shout hundreds of thousands
of people under Mass surveillance and
like have government handlers uh uh and
you just like completely erode any kind
of like uh sensitive cultural difference
they might have from the Han Chinese
population
and just like forcibly remove that like
excise it like it's an aberration I
think that's like completely I think
that that's completely unacceptable
I was trying to say they are obviously
heavily uh propagandized
okay but and and you know I just feel
like sometimes when I talk to socialists
they're just trying too hard to defend
China that's all
yeah
sure I mean there are there are
definitely people that go overboard and
will my my metric is this okay
if I criticized It in America and China
is doing it I'm going to criticize China
as well however when I make that
criticism people are so uh used to like
kind of having this uh unspoken defense
of America that even if they don't
really like America or criticize it they
think when I compare China to America
they think I'm like uh minimizing what
China is doing when in fact and this
happened with Russia as well no I'm not
minimizing it I'm saying it's one of the
worst things you can do because I
criticize America every day so when I
talk about labor camps for example or
prisons or the prison system in China
that is not supposed to mean that like
I'm defending the Chinese prison system
I'm criticizing it by comparing it to
one of the worst carceral states on the
planet the United States of America I
guess if the Chinese were looking at our
our prison system they would probably
think that was pretty cruel and yeah
bizarre and weird
and they're like yeah we just we just
put a bunch of uh ethnic Muslims in a
[__] camp and say bye-bye that's cool
I don't know
I guess we all got our problems don't we
folks what Dan I mean we literally do
that too yeah we've so well
we're not doing it now and we've I would
say that we've also pound-for-pound done
like definitively worse things to the
global uh population of Muslims with the
war on terror post 911
100 uh across the board but it's not a
competition it's not I'm not you know
and I agree with all that because you're
right I I think that like I said these
are the reasons why I'm like a little
worried I might not be able to get a
visa to get into China because you're
the number one sim bro they should let
you in quick no and you said that we're
doing re-education camps where are we
doing that right now re-education
re-education our ethnic uh we we did it
we have we have isolation
we do the thing is we have the same
thing is just not on U.S soil what
Guantanamo Guantanamo or black sex in
Syria and all over the Middle East I
mean we've been at war in the Middle
East for over two decades now on the
other side of the globe
there's 30 people in Guantanamo Bay
apparently
winding that one down little by little I
mean obviously that's [__] insane but
it's not the same first of all what
happens in Guantanamo Bay is insane no
what happens in Guantanamo Bay is is
you're not getting re-educated you're
just being tortured yeah you're just
being tortured yeah but like I I feel
like that's a different uh thing that's
what's going on who cares I mean it's
all bad okay I I agree I think this is
this is my assessment of the situation
as well I I think like I said like I say
time and time again the moment that I
compare it though the moment that I
compare it to China in any capacity
people have this expectation due to a
tremendous amount of propaganda from
Western media that like you have to just
say no the what the Chinese are doing is
uniquely evil uniquely bad it is a
Kindle Holocaust and and no one else is
doing anything that is anywhere near
that at all
but I think
and we're kind of talking in circles but
I feel like socialists are like no
China's amazing they're doing so much
amazing things I can't speak for other
she is handsome he's strong he's
beautiful and Central Casting there are
definitely people that that's the vibe I
get sometimes when I hear from there are
definitely people who defend uh China
like you would defend America like the
average Maga person would defend America
but you know that's not exactly a
commonplace uh thing that you can hear
you have to seek that out for sure
because
most people just genuinely hate China
they don't like it they don't they are
there's China is seen as like an
existential threat to uh our our you
know Global hegemonic power structure
that we've existed under people one
versus change on its face they don't
like that and to fear another country uh
coming to power because we know what
powerful countries do to others that no
longer have that power it's kind of like
um it's kind of like white people being
afraid of black people getting civil
liberties because you're like well I
know what what I would do if I'm or why
people thinking that they're going to be
in the minority right uh because I know
what I would do to minorities I know
what I've done to minorities when I
wasn't when I was in power you know what
I mean it's kind of like that
um
so I think overall there's a lot of
disdain
um I I don't know I I I criticize uh
what the Chinese government is doing
just like any other government but I
also do glaze up the good things that
they do
you know place them it's not yeah I
glaze them hard you glaze their Glizzy
yeah I think high speed rail is
incredible I think well one other thing
that I just mentioned like healthcare is
a massive problem in China as well
massive problem in China uh and they
haven't been able to solve that that's a
real issue
um there are areas that they have been
very prosperous on and very good at but
there are areas where they are failing
Healthcare being one of the main issues
as far as like rapid development goes
all right let's we're uh coming near low
on time about 20 minutes left so let's
talk let's continue on about Trump's
third indictment here is Hassan's
welcome poster
uh when you arrive at the airport okay
my head looks a little too small there
there's a new explosion back there son
explain that I thought they liked that
aesthetic
yeah that's what they think I don't know
about China I don't know right you said
Japan right right I said Japan and Korea
wait was it I didn't I see a clip of you
talking to a Japanese woman they're like
they would not find you attractive
oh yeah on Tick Tock I was talking to
kahoe uh who is a former uh Japanese
adult video actress she's incredible
person uh yeah Japanese people do not
find me attractive because uh you just
said they do no I'm talking about well
head head
actually this might not even work you
know it's in in Korea but no head size
to shoulder ratio is different than uh
being hairy Japanese people do not like
yeah Japanese women in general are not
appreciative of muscular guys and
they're not appreciative of hairy guys
and I am two of those things so no hair
okay
it's more of like a like a pale
androgynous pretty aesthetic that they
like they like twinks right well they
all are kind of uh you know I'm not
gonna say it
not even gonna say it Trump got is about
to get indicted for the third time
I'm not even gonna say it
I did everything right and indicted
let's see last week Trump received a
letter from special counsel Jack Smith
fake ass name having weirdo
just kidding I mean he does have a fake
name but I don't know if he's a weirdo
the target letter cited three statues
that could be applied to a prosecution
of Trump by the special counsel Jack
Smith including a potential charge of
conspiracy to defraud the United States
check out all these charges
ready for this I'm so ready
conspiracy to commit offense or defraud
um
Trump and his allies could face a
conspiracy charge based on fake electors
witness tampering
obstruction of an official proceeding
uh influencing or repeating and an
official proceeding
deep private deprivation deprivation of
rights under color of law
those are pretty uh what is that makes
it a crime for people acting under color
of law meaning any public officials or
law enforcement acting under their legal
authority to willfully deprive a person
of a right or privilege that's protected
under the Constitution okay
so um I mean this is pretty incredible
stop a third indictment for our boy
Donnie
do these indictments start to become
meaningless after a while uh to the
general population or do you think these
indictments are going to actually
influence people's perception of trump
I mean
I think people's influence people's
perception of Trump have been influenced
already in the sense that like uh people
have already made up their minds I think
either pretty solidly yeah they're
either pretty solidly in defense of
Donald Trump no matter what happens and
we put them in the 30 category of like
Kooks and crazies uh or
the the
larger population is I think kind of
sick of trump like he's no longer the
new dog you know what I mean he's no
longer the new player on the field he
doesn't have that uh that I'm actually
more moderate than you would think I'm
not the regular Republican
um attitude that he was able to present
in many respects he was much more racist
much more openly racist uh while still
Towing the line on the same old
Republican policies
um which which was unique uh but in
others uh I think he he kind of came
across as moderate like his LGBT uh uh
defense yeah uh well he like those are
the those are the types of unique things
like him regularly speaking about
corruption in Washington and like the
influence of like money in Washington
was
genuinely refreshing to a lot of people
obviously he didn't follow through on
any of those in a serious way uh he was
never going to but
but basically he he was seen as the guy
who said things that everyone else was
too afraid to say and once you're
president for four years you kind of we
know what it was like under his
leadership and
uh especially with the tail end of his
presidency being coveted I think that
really really uh destroyed any kind of
uh Goodwill that he may have called he
may have generated from like moderates
and independents and those in the
margins so uh I don't know what it's
going to look like it's a it's a race to
the bottom right now well with Biden on
the one hand not being charismatic not
being uh remotely inspirational are we
still sure that Biden can beat Trump
because Trump is pulling not that bad
um I can't make this assessment yet like
I have to see more uh as the you know as
the as the general election nears
I
I will caution everyone who is uh very
comfortable about a Biden victory
and remind them that Donald Trump lost
yes however there was a [__] major
hail Mary that a lot of people come like
neglectfully uh forget which was he got
coveted right before election it was
worse than the Jim Comey second Hillary
Clinton letter which we know put a dent
in Hillary Clinton's already failing
campaign
he got covered right before election as
as people were like desperately trying
to forget about covid on the Republican
side especially you think people didn't
vote for him because he got covered I
think it it reminded people how
devastating covet is it reminded people
you really think that affected the the
voting I didn't even thought about it
100 you haven't thought about it because
the media for some weird reason uh never
adds this into their analysis it's more
so that conversation is so hold on Focus
don't understand the mentality you're
speaking to there's some yeah
there's some dude
sitting on his porch with a with a piece
of lemongrass in his mouth playing a
banjo
that's not the guy the guy who's the guy
that guy doesn't even vote in usual
elections for the first time for Trump
describe the guy the guy living in a
Virginia suburb okay has like a decent
job like a high paying decent job has a
family okay is upper middle class and
wants tax breaks and uh will potentially
be swayed by Obama or or was swayed by
Obama but like really like Donald Trump
as this like truth teller you know what
I mean okay so it definitely has like
process when Trump gets coveted and he
says I'm not voting for him he doesn't
he doesn't like covet he doesn't like
the shutdowns but at the same time I'm
just like making one profile off the top
of my head but there are plenty of
people like this where he doesn't like
uh he doesn't like the shutdowns but
he's also terrified of coven because his
grandfather or his his dad died you know
what I mean and
um thinking about that thinking about
how how deep and dark of a pit that
everyone was in at that time either due
to Applebee's not being open or due to
the fact that they were staying at home
and genuinely worried about covid Trump
getting coveted right at the last second
um right before the election reminds
everyone of that of the dangers of covid
and and Trump's neglectful attitude uh
towards covet in an election that was
like centered around the economy being
eviscerated by covet and Trump's uh
neglectful actions so you think him
catching kovid was a signal to people
that he had not done a good job of yes
it was a reminder to people that maybe
wanted to forget about it especially and
I think that that played a huge role in
a lot of uh moderates finally like
moderates that were not exactly super
enthusiastic or Independents that were
not exactly super enthusiastic or even
some Republicans that were like
embarrassed by Trump's Behavior to go
all right [__] this I'm not voting
okay
yeah
well the ultimately a lot of those uh
suburbs that originally
voted for Donald Trump turned around and
did either a vote for Joe Biden or
didn't vote
um
so I think that was a that was a big
problem that is interesting okay I
haven't I haven't never heard that
analysis
um but there's more though if you look
at the midterms and the lackluster
performance from uh trump-backed
candidates during the midterms uh I
think Americans do have I mean they
voted for Biden because they wanted to
return to normalcy they wanted to go
back to brunch they wanted to stop
[__] thinking about politics all the
time they had politics fatigue so they
were just like just give me a normal guy
give me a normal guy that is just
running this [__] on autopilot I don't
want to think about it I don't want to
watch CNN I don't want to get like
psychic damage from what's going on this
isn't to say that you know the issues do
not persist of course they do but
Americans did not want to think about it
which is why they voted for the normal
guy candidate right they couldn't have
gone a more normal guy too it's like Joe
Biden's just like yeah he's like
he's like the archetypal uh president in
the movie that appears in one scene you
know what I mean he's just like generic
old white guy president yeah yeah so
they they voted for the generic old
white guy even though they knew that he
was old as hell even though he uh they
knew that he wasn't going to you know
make any campaign promises fulfill any
of those campaign promises in general
which he of course didn't
um then the economy uh went to [__] due
to Greed inflation and corporate
consolidation the war in Ukraine and
what it did to energy or what uh energy
developers uh took advantage of in that
regard and then Biden's uh Biden's
positives went away uh fairly quickly
even though he got a big boost
originally from being the guy who
finished the inoculation campaign and
being the guy who was leading the charge
when things opened up right
um there is people don't think about
uh these sorts of things in a rational
way they think about what how someone
makes you feel or they think about how
they feel at a certain point in time and
and Biden already Biden already had that
massive boost working for him and he
squandered that Goodwill over the course
of his presidency and he's very old and
he's not inspirational at all uh and uh
and I don't know what is it going I
don't know what's going to happen well
for that reason I'm excited for this all
to get started in a month
the first debate boy we are going to
Feast dude uh here's how it's looking
Trump is crushing DeSantis is crashing
yeah DeSantis is oh I can talk about
that for hours apparently pens didn't he
isn't even qualified he didn't qualify
for the debate for the debate because he
doesn't have enough individual donors he
only raised like 1.4 million dollars yep
yeah
who would vote for pants I don't know
but if you're a vice president and you
can't raise more than 1.4 million for
your campaign in a country of 350
million people no no the Trump what the
[__] the Trump Camp went and did January
6 and they were trying to hang him
straight up they brought Gala like he
doesn't even have the the Trump wouldn't
you wouldn't be so good to see Trump and
Pence on stage together and Trump's just
being like hey hey Mikey we're bringing
Out The Gallows again yeah I mean it
would be great for Content but I think
he could he could destroy DeSantis in a
similar fashion I want
uh you know blood boy DeSantis get
eviscerated by him that's what I'm look
I'm looking for but he doesn't want to
do debates he said he's not going to do
the debates who Trump oh he better not
wait I thought
Trump said that but come on no the
people need it when he says when he sees
the glitz and the Glam everybody's
showing up he's not gonna be able to
okay oh
the dog unplugs something I think oh I
genuinely think Trump not participating
in the debate will
um hurt him big time people and his fans
specifically they want to see him up
there
you know yeah causing damage I want to
see him up there I'm a fan he's got to
do it he has to do it um I think he also
Trump looks really good when he's
matched up against enemies and I think
right now Trump could very easily
portray DeSantis as a corporate stooge
uh and and maybe even recover some of
the uh recover some of the outsider
narrative by portraying the entire
Republican party infrastructure as like
built against them all these rhinos and
he can just very easily say like Ron
DeSantis is a rhino uh you know I I I
defended him foolishly and he's trying
to you know he's trying to destroy me
because he's like backed by the
Republican party they don't want me to
save America from Joe Brandon and um and
because Rhonda Sanchez is the Charisma
of a wet napkin uh he will look awful
next to Donald Trump he's gonna get so
mad yeah all it'll take for for Rhonda
sandus to tank even further in the polls
is for him to do that like ah like he
does that weird face every time he
reacts to something like he emotes like
such a freak you know I saw a recent
interview with Ronnie boy
and he's attempting to smile in the
beginning and it's just so unsettling
comfortable smile I'm trying to find
what where was there while you're
looking for that
I just want to show this uh tweet or not
tweet uh truth or whatever from Vivek is
actually popping off in some uh some
polls I love his lying about Christy
Grandma Swami is now beating the
sanctimonious Christy dead at his
stomach band
aydah Hutchinson a solid minus one
percent I'm up 44 points let's make
America great again Chris go dead at his
stomach dead as his stomach oh dead as
is that is
I'm not sure I understand I know what
he's trying to call him fat but like the
announcement like uh what do you call it
lap band yeah the yeah he's saying his
lap band didn't take because he's fat
still yeah his lap band the surgery to
get your stomach uh oh did he get that I
I don't know for sure but it might have
yeah I think Trump's implying oh yeah it
didn't work yes
that's fire yeah that's good um the so
as far as uh things that work to Biden's
Advantage is the Republicans still
basically controlling
every aspect of American existence from
the state legislature level but the
Democrats haven't done a really good job
of like uh communicating that uh you
have the Roe v Wade anxiety still that's
very prominent and very real
um and some of these freaks are still
gung-ho about uh further restricting
access to these uh
is really important uh types of Health
Care so
I think that that definitely plays in uh
in favor uh for for Joe Biden however
the Democratic party I I hear nothing
from them I do not hear anything from
them as far as like uh this is bad look
at how bad these guys are like their
messaging is is completely out of whack
but so is the Republican parties like
Gavin Newsom
I mean as a candidate I think Gavin
Newsom
is a horrible neoliberal cut out that is
everything that is wrong with the
Democratic party
first of all I mean look around we live
in California we pay a lot of taxes
which you know neither of us have
problem with except where is that being
utilized stuff bro okay well I don't
have a problem with it where is that
being utilized your your roads are full
of [__] potholes we do not have like
adequate we do not have adequate public
transit homelessness is a gigantic
problem born out of the completely awful
uh housing market that's backed by uh
like what like I don't know that those
Solutions are so easy to tackle like
they're not the homeless the
homelessness thing is always to me
seemed a bit unfair in the sense that
the entire countries all of their
homeless they come to the West Coast
because the weather's nice and the
social services are better it's like
that's not necessarily the the main
reason actually Ethan that that is that
does happen but I was just reading about
this a couple weeks ago
um a very recent study that I think uh
was done in San Francisco
um I think by the university there you
see up there that um fake news brother
they found that um population in
California it was like it was like 85
California natives really yeah wouldn't
expect that no what you're saying does
happen though they do like other states
like hot if you go to Detroit I mean if
you're homeless in Detroit you die
right yeah there's people from
California don't travel to Detroit
because the it's nice to be homeless
there I mean okay obviously I know but
there's homeless so
if that were the case it's harder if
that was exclusively the case then you
wouldn't see homelessness skyrocketing
in every other part of the country like
you also correctly pointed out
um it's it's skyrocketing in every uh it
doesn't just it doesn't go against it
just means there's no I know the reason
why it's like massively a problem in in
you know a heavily populated urbanized
areas of Texas for example like Austin
is precisely because of the housing
market because that is the one
consistent factor it's heavily limited
it's heavily limited there is no
adequate supply of uh low-cost housing
um and our our rental options are
eviscerated whether it's through Airbnb
or through people parking uh their
assets on their on the already limited
amount of housing there is no good uh
even uh mixed income uh developed
housing there's no affordable housing
and and that's the number one reason why
people become homeless they get priced
out of the housing market even when they
have a job they get priced out of the
housing market and then their Journey
towards like becoming the guy that you
see on the street who's like taking a
[__] on the street who's like a very
clearly uh having like an episode
regularly
um their Journey towards that and uh you
know starts off at that point we we
often forget the the invisible
homelessness any of us could be that
dude taking a [__] on the street
I mean yeah all of us are could be
anything closer to that person and being
that person uh then uh some of us more
close some of us closer than others but
we are significantly closer to that
person than we are to Elon Musk
it's infinitely more likely that we
become that person then we become Elon
Musk that's for sure but people don't
recognize the existential threat that uh
the the
uh for-profit uh commoditized heavily
monetized housing market does I I'm not
I I'm not super familiar with like what
California is doing to prevent
homelessness what they're doing to
you know help the homeless so I don't
know I mean
is Gavin Gavin Newsom doing like a worse
job than his predecessors at dealing
with the issue
he's just not doing enough to deal with
it as the problem worsens
um so it's not it's not entirely upon
him to fix and it's a problem that is
almost impossible to fix because of the
current uh structure that we operate
under where housing is a a an asset like
your house is an asset it's it's a
really important for wealth accumulation
people want their housing prices to
consistently go up
and that uh can only be done by limiting
the amount of available housing
and and also on top of that uh you know
different types of zoning restrictions
that you uh that you enforce what can
Gavin Newsom do about like in LA the
zoning the zoning laws are [__]
insane so I'll give you a great example
of what Gavin Newsom fails to do okay so
every every time we have an election
there's a ballot measure where we're
like Hey we're gonna add a five percent
additional purchase uh tax on properties
that are over five million dollars right
seems great what will that fund well
that will find a homelessness yeah I've
already guessed it was uh don't hate
it's gonna fund uh it's gonna fund
homelessness initiatives right yeah and
we also on top of that have an 80
billion dollar Surplus right now in
California due to a tremendous amount of
of uh you know wealth that was generated
during covet here in California uh and
wealthy people not really leaving in
droves in the way that Joe Rogan and
Elon Musk claim they are
um
and where does all that money go well it
actually sits they just park it because
even if we do fund these programs and we
have these uh you know doughy-eyed uh
council members or or uh people working
in Municipal governments that genuinely
want to make positive change happen real
estate developers and homeowners
associations and people that have a
vested interest in the housing market
being as [__] so what can you do what
can Gavin do they stop it they stop uh
they stop initiatives like project home
key which is supposed to repurpose
vacant hotels into a permanent shelter
for homeless people
how does he stop they just they stop it
they look at San Francisco yeah like
whenever there is any kind of uh
whenever there's any kind of initiative
to like build uh new homes or build uh
or you know change the zoning
restrictions that exist everybody goes
this destroys the the culture of the
neighborhood how does Gavin Newsom enter
how does he affect the local politics I
mean as a governor you have a lot of
powers I think you can get assistance
from the federal government as well if
you are genuinely interested in doing so
but since the people voted on it he
should be utilizing the bully bully
pulpit more effectively as the governor
to be like no we're doing this like [__]
you I don't give a [__] eminent domain
suck my dick you know what I mean when
there's a will there's a way and the
problem is there is no will from the
Democratic party uh which is a
stronghold in California and they are
very comfortable knowing full well that
no one is really going to go and vote
for a republican it's not like the
Republicans are advocating for anything
positive right but it is very dangerous
when you think about a place like Los
Angeles uh where you have our very own
Donald Trump Style real estate developer
billionaire you know run for mayor and
and and launch a relatively successful
it's almost there yeah yeah so that that
is not
that that's not spelling trouble well he
had a solution to homelessness at least
a final solution
well oh yeah he did he wanted to [__]
but a solution nonetheless yeah he he
wanted to put him in camps yeah away
from uh the population except like that
again doesn't identify or even capture
the problem or solve it because there's
always new people becoming homeless
every single [__] day because they're
priced out of the housing market so in
short we don't like
our boy slick-haired Gavin news I mean I
like him he's hot he's beautiful he's
hot he's he he's a cheater he's a big
cheater he's got a lot of Oppo on him
that will uh really I don't know if he's
like charismatic enough and I don't know
if the Democratic party audience is like
receptive enough these kinds of
Personality flaws he does the Republican
[__] your mom dude no problem he
literally no he has he [__] like he he
is done like double adultery numerous
times you know what I mean he's got that
yeah Kimberly Guilfoyle is his ex
right that was such a weird girlfriend
oh what a weird it's not that weird
though these people it's all in it's
it's [__] he was married
it's all we're still living in America
in Austria in this country listen
I I listen
Gavin Newsom has got to be way more
complete rounded human being than Donald
Trump Jr I mean how do you go from Gavin
maybe he's a demon maybe he's just
better at uh putting on the map Donald
Trump Junior he's I've always gotten
literally Richard Bateman vibes from
Gavin Newsom he seems like a psychopath
I think really killed people really do
that I mean he's he's very handsome he
certainly charismatics but he has a lot
of flaws and the main one is one two
issues that I'd rather would you rather
[__] him or Donald Trump Jr oh him easy
but here's the thing enough said here's
way more is than Junior if he's running
if he's running for office if he's
running for presidency there are two
things that he has to either combat
through messaging or genuinely solve in
a meaningful way uh the second part is
much harder crime in California is a
consistent narrative that one is easy to
destroy because that one is mostly just
misinformation peddling
um but he would have to message around
that to be like no that's not the case
okay I actually saw a clip of him doing
a pretty decent job of that recently he
did that on Sean Hannity oh yeah it was
awesome everybody's it was it was going
viral on Tick Tock with the kids more
importantly though more importantly than
crime in California like I said which is
not as severe a problem as the way that
the media has represented so that's a
messaging issue which he can get over
because he is charismatic the other
problem is homelessness which is a real
issue which he can't actually get over
without uh genuinely solving all right
Rick or not Rick all right Gavin if
you're listening
let's get on that homelessness if he
fixed if he if he put a dent in the
homelessness uh problem in any tangible
meaningful uh significant capacity he
could easily run for president and and
have a shot at it uh other contenders
that I believe uh especially Governors
are Gretchen Whitmer who has a lot of
positives yeah a lot of people like her
uh she's also charismatic she's hot
she's like a strong Buxom what's what uh
you know real American woman I mean she
has big she's just like I don't know I
want to be vulgar she's like big boobs
doesn't it well kind of she's like milk
porn she has what's your name she has a
strong dominating presence that is not
like overboard it's it's a it's it reads
well yeah it's like a real American
woman you know what I mean here she is
so she's Buxom you say
[Laughter]
um the other one who is actually
significantly no I know I'm just I'm I'm
I'm wondering if that checks if that
checks out like I'm not saying she's got
big titties I I didn't mean it like that
I meant like she's uh
she's like a real woman she's like a
powerful she has a powerful stature yeah
Buxom is a word that typically used to
describe someone who's full figured or
voluptuous yeah no I think I used anyone
plump and healthy can be Buxom yeah
Buxom implies having a full chest
I think I'm using it correctly and not
like saying that she's got big titties I
I I'm trying to say that like I don't
know if you can say that I don't know if
it means
I mean like she is yeah she's
full-figured she got some fat [__]
titties Nancy Pelosi the goddamn shame
that is not what I meant Nancy Pelosi
could die and peace knowing that
all the time I but like if I was talking
about her titties I would openly say it
that's not what I mean I'm talking about
like like you're you're uh your physical
presence and the aura is very important
when you when you think about who you're
voting for in the minds of like the
American Consciousness the American
voters
um the other actually also voluptuous
person rotund I would say is JB pritzker
we have another voluptuous lady and
Jerry pritzker is not a lady uh but
instead a a handsome lad about the most
Chicago man to have ever been born yeah
that's a buxom man right there bro yeah
nobody's ever been more from Chicago
than this guy yeah he's that's a Buxton
brother he also is I beg to differ there
yeah except John Wayne Gacy Maybe he
also is seen as a a relatively positive
figure which is interesting because
Chicago is probably one of the most
crime-infested corrupt like Illinois is
one of the worst states for the
Democratic party because like you just
have to be literally a a criminal to be
a politician in Illinois
some of which have even went to jail as
a matter of fact like uh
I still I still don't know how to say
his name correctly um so he is uh he's
populist
uh he's a billionaire which is bad but
uh but he's so fat that I think it like
overcomes that negative aspect of like
being a billionaire
uh he's Pleasant he means well
uh even if he [__] up sometimes like
it's the the energy that he exudes is
like well-intentioned so what are the
chances that we that we get someone else
running instead of oh this time around
no it's not happy that's yeah all of
this I think is for 2028. that [__]
sucks because the Democratic party uh is
not gonna he's not even background on
the
the Democratic party is never going to
see ground on on the incumbent's
advantage and they it's just not going
to happen because that would imply that
the the party is not strong I'm sure
they've done the mental calculation I
don't even think this is more like a Joe
Biden wants to run again type situation
I don't even know if he knows what day
it is I think it's more so that they
probably crunch the numbers internally
and they see like they do a cost benefit
analysis and they're like we didn't
really prop up any figures as a as a as
a substitute for Joe Biden it's
certainly not going to be Kamala Harris
who is a Charisma black hole
um and they have also purposely like
Center on all of the worst missions
possible that a VP could ever take on
um they made her look really bad on top
of you know just because you ever switch
out VP
that just happened that'd be so
humiliating for her yeah no that would
because he's gonna I mean there's like a
pretty good chance he dies in his next
term they would they would uh I think he
would get punched statistically yeah no
I think I think a big chunk of Voters
would be very upset if yeah because like
you can't sell Kamala Harris as like a
beacon of prosperity as a black woman
the first black woman VP or whatever and
then rip that away yeah okay hold on
real bad I think Joe Biden is 80 right
now average life expectancy of a of a
USA man oh he's he's already he's three
years 77. yeah he's three years time
yeah so you give him another I mean he's
gonna get reelected in a year when he
finishes his second term that man is
going to be 85. yeah that's straight up
Jello years he might he might be dead by
then yes I mean he's like he's
definitely being propped up by
incredible amounts of like medical
Cocktails so I mean oh yeah there's like
probably a I would say even a higher
than 50 chance that he dies in office I
think there is a there is a likelihood
that he dies in office yes uh and
no she's not gonna be good it kind of
sucks that like the first female
president is going to be by default and
not elected that does suck yeah I mean
if only we could have had Hillary right
yeah I mean I I think it would be cool
symbolically but I'm just chilling in
Cedar Rapids I mean are there any like
modern industrialized countries that we
consider you know similar to the United
States that haven't had
uh woman head of state like the UK
Germany even as France had a woman head
of state I think they've all I think
they all have maybe with Le Pen yeah
they got close with Le Pen they're
probably going to with Le Pen uh 100 yes
they have had
she was she was prime minister from 1991
to 1992. Edith Cresson
in France yeah I believe the prime
minister is uh is less than the
president in France they they have a
similar first one to do so and only
woman until Elizabeth born was appointed
in 2022. I don't know but my point just
being we're way behind the curve here oh
yeah way way way way
yeah 100 percent
um for sure all right listen we're over
time
was a socialist okay would you consider
Kamala to be Buxom no no okay I know I
don't think so like I don't I don't
think she has small titties no that's
not what I'm saying no uh Kamala hair is
is does not read as like uh I don't
think she reads uh by by uh like
Democratic audiences as uh as like a
woman with a
like a rugged Midwestern uh relatability
she is yeah she doesn't have uh big
gretch's uh rugged Midwestern appeal and
relatability uh Kamala Harris is I think
seen as more of like uh like an elitist
institutionalist uh
who is uh barred out all the time like
she has I do things closer to Hillary
Clinton than she is to right to that
okay as an image
all right guys listen
what a great time we've had here huh
folks folks we've been here we've talked
about it all and we've been indicted for
a third time uh
Hassan nice to see you yeah it's good to
be back
uh oh oh [__] I gotta go you guys the
Grim Reaper's here
but um
yeah I think uh it's about to start
heating up here on leftovers as we
approach the first debates and
everything it's gonna be fun it's
already heating up in here literally
it's hot it's very hot in here today
yeah it's hot and hopefully the most
Buxom woman we're just gonna keep our
eyes on those Buxom chess let's let's
not okay uh can I uh offer folksie as
maybe an ultimate yeah they bought them
I'm just I I a folksy truck that means
big tittied
that's just how people use that word you
got to be careful in the Buxom we can do
a poll
I mean we don't have to let's do it I
will not use Buxom I probably will yeah
you should rotate that out I'll probably
keep using it can you do a poll okay
what does Buxom mean big titty Well I
obviously it does in certain contexts
that's that's the that's the colloquial
meaning of bucks that's literally the
only time I've ever heard that word is
until today what are the options yes or
no it can mean other things two itch
right
or how about this how about this when
you hear Buxom do you
think
some do you think big titty yes or no
yes
no is this helpful for you son I don't
care sure
I'm doing Ops for you brother healthy
and Hardy
in the tit area
let's see here so let's take it the ball
when you hear Buxom do you think big
tits I'm getting cooked in these girls
man so it's right now it's 75 yes and
I'm just I'm doing you a 72. okay you're
also playing exploding Milk porn in the
background this is like subliminal
messaging no it's not I just I'm trying
to save you from attention
the sanctity of the vote here
we need to reach out
count the votes all right well it's 69
Blaze yo 69 on uh about uh
dude you guys are funny for that all
right listen guys we'll see you tomorrow
it's Friday we've got oh [__]
thank you